yes so I'm actually not here to talk
about communism I just really like that
dog and what I'm actually here to talk
about oh we got a clicker
you know keyboard cannot be identified
this is fine doesn't work why was I yes
not communism actually um I'm here to
talk about something that has often been
compared to communism bye bye they so
don't like it
which is in fact open source and just
gonna dive right in I want to start off
by telling you a little story about this
fellow called Richard Stallman in 1984
or there abouts Richard encountered the
printer so Richard was working at the
MIT artificial intelligence lab back in
the day and they'd just gotten a new
printer so this is something they used
to do the hardware manufacturers of the
time the mi ta AI lab among others had a
reputation for having enough some clever
people that so they would give them free
hardware and expect good feedback and
and software patches back and it was all
very nice so they just got a new printer
from from Xerox they they just made this
thing called a photocopier and they had
figured that in fact this photocopier
thing could be turned into a printer as
well instead of just receiving the image
data from the that the photo part of the
photocopier they they could actually
just pipe data from a computer into the
printer part of the photocopier and this
was all very new and exciting back then
it was like even more exciting than
laser printers since I
fear the previous Britta they had was
the laser printer that had the
unfortunate habit of printing circles as
ovals and and diagonal lines a sort of
sine waves and that sort of thing but on
the other hand the Xerox engineers have
designed this thing to be basically
crude at all times there would always be
somebody at the photocopier making
photocopies so a design priority was not
to make sure that the thing doesn't Jam
it was more to make it easy for whoever
was at the machine to unjam it which is
great for a photocopier I'm not so great
for a printer so the problem occurred
that they the printer would get jammed a
lot and somebody would have to go and
unjam it which happened to Richard one
day he had a very large print job he
went to the printer about an hour later
to check if it was done and he found
that not only was his print job not done
but the printer had jammed like 2/3
print jobs back so he was very upset
this is something he'd actually dealt
with previously as well how the old
printer tended to jam as well because
printers and what she done is so he was
not a technical engineer so he couldn't
make the printer Jam less but what it
could do was patched the software so
that it would pull the printer see if it
was jammed and if it was it would email
everybody in the print queue saying the
printer is jammed you should go fix it
on the theory that if you just email
though the person whose job has gotten
jammed they might not be responsible
enough to go fix it but it's more likely
if you email everybody that somebody's
gonna go sort it out for you so Richard
decided to implement this patch for the
new printer as well so he went to look
for the printer drivers of foix and he
couldn't find it he wasn't too worried
he knew that these things usually showed
up eventually didn't even really bother
pinging Xerox about it just just waited
patiently for the software to surface as
it usually did and months later he
decided even waited long enough it
didn't seem to be surfacing so he are
surrounded and discovered that the
fellow had actually written the printer
software had just left Xerox and taken
up a professorship at Carnegie Mellon to
which Richard frequently had occasion to
to visit for work so he just waited
another month or so until he found
himself was coming to Carnegie Mellon
and went to see the fellow who wrote the
printer software and asked him basically
found him
Richard was was an engineering and nerd
so he was very terse it just went to the
fan a self ISM said hello I'm Richard
I'm from MIT
we got your printer and I had the
software because I'd like to patch it
and the fellow looks a bit uncomfortable
and said well I'd love to give you the
software but I've signed a nondisclosure
agreement so I can't and Richard have no
idea how to even deal with this it was
an awkward social situation so being the
person he was he just basically said
nothing got up and left and felt very
embarrassed and very furious about this
situation so
basically this is how the free-software
movement formed because Richards anger
at not getting that piece of printed
driver sort of blossomed over the next
couple of years into the idea that he
needed to form a movement to make sure
that software was always free and
available as it had been in in the
golden day some of I suppose US academic
hacker culture everybody shared software
freely among each other and and nobody
saw any reason to actually sort of horse
of barren and unguarded secrets so what
came out of that was the Free Software
Foundation and the GNU general public
license or the GPL for short which is a
free software license are basically
God's the principles that Richards
decided on to to safeguard the idea of
free software so basically the free
software movement is about the idea that
software is the communal good and must
stay in the public domain where it can
be studied and modified freely that's
the heart of the free software idea
right now we're in the late 80s and at
this point not too many people have
actually even heard of free software it
wasn't the movement that was growing
very quickly then in the mid 90s that
are about this fellow called
Eric Raymond published a treatise called
the cathedral and the bazaar which
introduced arrival but very similar idea
a compatible idea of sorts called open
source so this fellow Eric Raymond
published the text called the cathedral
and the bazaar and the idea of this was
more pragmatic than the face of
commitment so
the software still remains in the open
under open source but the idea is not so
much to preserve sort of the socialist
idea of sharing in faith of flat but
it's more the practical notion that if
software is out there in the open then
other people can review code or the
people can contribute it to your code
and this is the way to make your code
better quite simply it's a strictly
utilitarian philosophy
unlike the frankly the socialism of free
software but still argue arguably has
the greater good in mind so the
flagships
of the open source movement at the time
were Linux the operating system or the
kernel which was using the GPL license
but definitely sort of politically was
more aligned with open source and free
software and there was this thing called
Netscape which started off from the
other direction as a piece of
proprietary software which the company
Netscape decided to to put to make
available under an open-source license
and this turned into the Mozilla browser
that we know today and the Mozilla
Foundation so the open source movement
which which grew out of the 90s and the
the 2000 tended to not be too keen on
the GPL depending rather on what they
called permissive licenses like BSD and
and MIT these did not include the the
GPS Sharon eye closes but was more about
pragmatically allowing software to you
to corporate open source software
without needing to share back
necessarily but preserving the the
rights you were granted under the
license for this the open source of with
typically so this was more in tune with
the idea with a pragmatic idea if it's
all stats everybody can use this
software for whatever they like even to
bid for pricier stuff laughs but the
software itself has to stay available
and getting to this decade it sort of
changed a bit and so you have the
idealism of free software and you have
the pragmatism of open source and it's
sort of turning into something onto
getting you again it's something a bit
like us maybe programming as self
expression where the artist isn't
concerned with community improvement or
collective collective bug-fixing so much
is putting their work out there to be
appreciated for its own sake we're still
I think myself as a community trying to
figure out the shape of this new
community but it's really exciting to me
because in many ways this has been my
own motivation for writing software from
from the very start today but now I feel
like like people are actually writing
software just for the fun of it or for
the lyosha of it and I think that's
really wonderful but in summary whether
you see open-source as socialism or
pragmatism or or even art what it all
points down to ultimately and this is
what makes it so extremely important as
an idea is that open-source gives us
agency and what I mean by that is that
open-source actually grants us the power
first of all as Richard demanded to
create so we have the the source code
for the software we use available to us
so that we can easily customize it
improve it and repair it as we see fit
which empowers us as users as well as
programmers and it enhances the larger
community of the users and programmers
and this is perhaps the most important
of all it also gives us the power to
learn how software is built
we have the vast bulk of open-source
software available to us and we have the
ability to examine it to learn how it
works and how to build similar systems
of our own and and anyone can do this I
mean given the admittedly not
unrestricted resource of time at least
there are no gatekeepers to the
knowledge it's readily accessible to
anybody without eating to pay anything
without needing to get accepted into a
university or anything like that
it's all right out there in the open and
that is actually really powerful but
what's so crucially important about the
idea of open source so to clarify this
well we're missing a slide I know there
was an exercise right okay to clarify
let me tell you the story of the man who
wanted to go to Mars let's call him
Elon after the the fiction of Martian
leader from a science fiction story by
some rocket scientist I forget
coincidentally of course
so his ambition is no less than to
actually send humans to Mars and put a
human colony on the planet Mars now
interestingly at least for the short
term his company SpaceX is actually
developing the technology they need to
facilitate going to Mars out in the open
citing the fact that their only real
competitors are Public Interest agencies
like NASA which actually don't don't
keep their work a secret at all so it's
all happening in the open they're all
sharing then take the technological
advances openly including this this
commercial operations place
my mic is falling off just a second
there we go so in a very real sense you
could say that space access is an open
source company in a larger open source
community just that they're not actually
doing software so much as space as it
were now imagine if this were not the
case imagine perhaps if someone with
different ideas about intellectual
property or in charge of the company
this of course this this picture is
randomly chosen imagine if the knowledge
needed to send our species to another
planet was locked away inside some
company some company's intellectual
property vaults as it were imagine if
some company was the gatekeeper to
humanity's ability to actually go in and
colonize the universe and putting back a
bit from the granulation of space travel
imagine if companies controlled the
knowledge of how to write different
kinds of software inside their corporate
silos
imagine if the only way to learn how to
be a serious programmer was to sign up
with some giant corporation and you were
only allowed to use the knowledge you
gained from it as as directed by the
corporation or you will get shut down by
by patent lawsuits or similar this is
sort of thing that keeps me up at night
honestly so the point I'm trying to make
it's that it's not ultimately about the
software that we write it's about the
knowledge we put out that of how to
build the software that we write the
programs we leave behind they're not
really our legacy as programmers what
we're really contributing is the
knowledge that we develop the knowledge
that we discover and the knowledge that
we pass on so to me it's actually really
important that we think very seriously
about how we protect that knowledge
which which belongs to all of us from
being locked away behind walls of
intellectual property and whatnot so I'm
sorry I'm going to get
I'm goes again into the legal details
now the GPL I mentioned what happens to
be one mechanism for this and I've got
actually a cheat sheet for you now if
you believe in this idea of preserving
the knowledge at all costs you want to
use the license that actually and source
that this happens
so the GPL says that not only must your
code remain freely available it also
cannot be linked with proprietary
software so the idea there is to
encourage everything to exist in a fully
open ecosystem now if you have the term
viral applied to the GPL that was sort
of Microsoft's way of referring to to
this idea in this negative way as they
could think of and the GPL is actually
really strict about this but in the
interest of sort of the socialist idea
of sharing knowledge this is a less
demanding version of the GPL called the
the lesser GPL as GPR and there's also
the Mozilla Public License which kind of
makes us the same requirements as the GP
out but it's still it's constrained just
to your particular project or even
particular files inside of that project
so you think the GPR kind of goes a
little bit too far you might want to
have a look at the Mozilla license which
is also quite decent and finally if
you're not actually making software but
things like writing or visual arts or
music then you can consider the creative
commons share-alike license share alike
is particularly close and the Creative
Commons license which tests SATs and
you're free to copy and modify this as
you please but you have to if you do so
you have to publish your derivative work
under the same license making it too
freely available now this is all from
the perspective of somebody who really
want to make sure that that free stuff
what happens you might not be
person I am but it's still a reasonable
phone and actually a lot more common for
people to just want to make sure that
their work is free and available to
everybody and they that everybody can
use it as they like this is basically
open source and in this case I'd like to
make a plea to you because I think the
most popular license for this by far is
the MIT license and BSD is also quite up
there but can I ask you please if this
is how you feel about so if I consider
the apache license because MIT is is is
home quite fine as a license it's very
short which a lot of people like but a
lot of the protections that offers are
implied by the wording of the MIT
license being as short as the days like
for instance patient protections the MIT
license says something like everybody's
free to use the software without
restriction which implies there has to
be a patient grant if the author of the
software owns the patent for the
software as well now the apache license
actually has things like this the patent
crowns in in plain text inside the
license so it's an explicit grant
whereas MIT tends to usually hold up in
court for this sort of thing it is
actually a lot better to have this
language specifically in the license so
if you're on the permissive side of
open-source I would like to urge you to
please consider the apache license for
your next project rather than MIT or of
course the GPL or the mozilla license if
you like so just at the end this is
where it gets social this is the awkward
posthumous talk because it would be
almost dishonest of me not to address
what might well be considered the
elephant in the room at this point
because you only that our community
leaders sometimes turn out to be a bit
rubbish and Richard as it happens
Richard Stallman it's not necessary an
exception to this I don't think he's
actually malicious in any real sense but
the truth is is
it says some pretty awful things I don't
think he means to hurt people but it's
more a matter of not knowing quite how
to behave properly in civilized society
and I mean I don't mean to excuse him
actually it is a bit problematic for the
leader of the free software movement to
to behave in this way and maybe it's
time for him to step down and when it
comes to Eric Raymond I'm not even going
to go that he's literally the worst
person in existence I just feel it's
important to mention that and my purpose
in going to this rather dark place at
the end of the talk is to stress that
even though the idea of open-source been
always have sort of sprung from the most
saintly of people it's not about the
people in the and we shouldn't be
treating these people as heroes which
not really treating anybody as heroes
and what matters is the idea of open
source or whichever direction you
approach it from whether it is from the
left or from the right or permissive
restrictive care or don't care
all of that it's not about the people
it's about the idea and the idea what it
comes down to in the end is the
knowledge embedded in the community
that's what's so important to protect
the knowledge of how to write software
and more broadly the knowledge of how to
do anything we as humans are able to do
even one day you and me we're going to
go to the stars and the knowledge to do
that we must preserve that at all costs
and that is what open source is really
all about thank you so much for enduring
this enjoy the book
you